this coming week is the observance of
veterans day when we remember
all those who've served in the nation's
military of course some
never made it home from their
assignments including members of the
elite special forces operations units
this morning the story of a foundation
that is fulfilling a battlefield promise
to educate the children of these fallen
warriors catherine herridge has their
story
staffs aren't sure his actions are in
keeping with the finest traditions of
military service
it was just a really special day i've
been proud of him for this for the past
10 years and now i just get to share
that with the world
miranda schur describes her husband ron
a medal of honor recipient
as a soft-spoken force of nature
he always pushed himself every day to be
the best version of himself to help
others a green beret medic
staff sergeant shurer was recognized for
heroic actions in afghanistan
at the battle of shock valley in 2008
sure
repeatedly exposed himself to enemy fire
to save
10 afghan commandos and four teammates
we work together as a tight knit family
we trusted one another
and we share a bond that's far greater
than words can describe
in 2009 shure left the military and
joined the secret service
as part of a counter assault team
protecting the president
special operators are and special forces
are
called the quiet professionals and then
he joined the secret service where they
kind of say they stay on
on the sideline of history and so i said
he was very good at finding the coolest
job possible that nobody was supposed to
notice
but in 2016 ron began to experience
severe back pain
when he sought medical care he received
a devastating diagnosis
stage four lung cancer you documented
ron's
cancer journey yes why did you do that
by talking about the cancer right away
and sharing it openly that made it
not powerful and not something that was
this big
thing kind of weighing on us even while
sick ron continued donating money from
each paycheck
to the special operations warrior
foundation the nonprofit funds
education for all children who lose a
parent serving in special operations
from preschool through college even
knowing that
his cancer journey would ultimately
likely come to this result
you know it wasn't on our radar that our
family would be covered by it my husband
my best friend
our hero in may at just 41 years old
ron lost his three-year battle against
cancer
what most people don't really take into
account i think
is that family behind ron
miranda tyler and cameron they're
serving as well
clay huttmacher is the president of the
special operations warrior foundation
the foundation was started in the
aftermath of the failed rescue attempt
for the 52 hostages held in tehran
we lost eight americans three marines
five air force that left behind 17 kids
the survivors of that mission made a
commitment
at that time to take care of the
education of those 17 kids
we've had a nearly 1500 children in our
program since 1980 and
there's 908 right now that are in the
program that we've committed to funding
the special operations warrior
foundation recently expanded their
program
to include medal of honor families like
the shores and you know the really cool
thing is
our mentors are graduates from our
program
like ebony cheryl whose father major
jeffrey sherrill
a special forces doctor was killed in
1996
when she was just four years old he just
wanted us
to not have money
get in the way of us living out our
dream
was there a point um in high school or
maybe middle school
where you weren't sure your family could
afford college
yeah but my dad wanted so badly for us
to get an education and
i really wanted to do that for my family
so that we can
just turn our lives around and and just
get to a better place
cheryl reached out to the special
operations warrior foundation for
assistance
when they said okay everything's covered
we asked like okay well how much
they're like all of it it's all covered
and i am
forever grateful for that since
graduating with a film degree in 2014
cheryl has been paying it forward as a
mentor with the foundation
sometimes you just need the support of
somebody with that lived experience just
to talk to
that sense of community is comforting
for miranda schurr and her two sons
due to covet 19 ron's funeral was
delayed until last month
at arlington national cemetery even
though obviously their life won't ever
be the same
without their father they're growing up
with so many people
that care about them and care about us
because they cared about ron and knowing
they're going to have that
i know my kids are going to be okay for
cbs this morning saturday
katherine herridge burke virginia
you wish there weren't children that
needed it but it brings just a different
meaning to no man left behind
when you think about what they're doing
and no matter who wins these elections
these quiet professionals keep working
for
you and us that's right all of us here
to remember